buenas tardes
se producen más de cientos de millones
de toneladas de residuos por año la
tierra nuestra casa parece convertirse
cada vez más en un inmenso depósito de
porquería
y así estamos
no estamos así
tirando basura por cualquier lado pero
no en todos los países pasa lo mismo
aunque son pocas las excepciones por
ejemplo suiza es uno de los países más
limpios y amigables con el medio
ambiente
se posicionó como el país que más
recicla más lo utiliza y más reduce con
una policía que se encarga de la basura
y que aplica multas de hasta diez mil
dólares
nosotros desde uruguay cuando vemos esto
pensamos como lo lograron
cómo empezó todo
todo empezó a partir de la crisis
ecológica de 1986 con un catastrófico
incendio que provocó la contaminación
total del aire y los ríos de alemania
holanda y suiza
los países iniciaron acciones conjuntas
para resolver la crisis mientras seguían
produciendo millones de residuos que
sólo la empeoraba no
entonces los suizos se dieron cuenta que
tenían que hacer algo para solucionar el
desastre
y plantearon reformas al sistema
sanitario
y lo implementaron
y nosotros en uruguay que hacemos
nosotros le damos la espalda a la basura
en nuestra casa cuando tiramos la basura
nos olvidamos no pensamos más en eso no
pensamos adónde va a parar
pero estoy segura que si todos
visitaremos al menos una vez el basurero
de montevideo nos replantearíamos las
cosas
en todas las casas montevideanas se
generan en la totalidad de las casas
monterianas se generan 1200 toneladas de
residuos por día
y ese número va en aumento año a año
y adónde va a parar todo esto alucina
felipe cardoso que es el sitio de
disposición final de montevideo
que hoy tiene una superficie equivalente
a 6 estadios centenarios
a esta oficina cada día se le suman en
total dos mil 600 toneladas de residuos
más aunque probablemente todos estos
números no nos digan nada porque no
tenemos una relación no nos podemos
imaginar cuánto será tanta cantidad de
residuos pero para que se hagan una idea
las bolsas de basura llegan se amontonan
y generan montañas que alcanzan los 40
metros de altura esto equivale a bueno
esto equivale a un edificio de 15 pisos
más o menos
el sitio de disposición final felipe
cardoso es el punto más alto de
montevideo después del cerro de
montevideo
el problema radica en que los residuos
que llegan no se descomponen
se calcula que si seguimos a este ritmo
en dos años ya no vamos a tener dónde
tirar nuestra basura es por eso que
necesitamos cambios de lo contrario qué
vamos a hacer
en que estamos pensando
estamos pensando
pensamos que cuando ya no tengamos donde
tirar deshecho vamos a dejar de
producirlos pensamos ampliar un nuevo
vertedero y vamos a abrir uno nuevo
la población se opone a los nuevos
lugares propuestos para vertederos es
que les hago una pregunta a quien le
gustaría tener un vertedero cerca de su
casa
o que se ubica un vertedero cerca de un
arroyo
entonces vamos a esperar a tener un
desastre ecológico como el de suiza para
reaccionar
los invito a no esperar no esperar a que
se completa el vertedero no esperar a
que aumente la contaminación y que ya no
tengamos cómo solucionarlo por eso hoy
vengo a proponerles que se apropien y
desarrollen el proyecto resuena proyecto
que ya estamos llevando a cabo en mi
liceo el 'juan 23
mi nombre es agustina pero acá podría
estar alejandro serrana antonio o
cualquiera de las 900 personas que ya
estamos formando parte de este proyecto
es por eso que todos deberían estar acá
pero como los 900 no entramos acá estoy
y trataré de representarlo de la mejor
manera posible trataré de transmitir
nuestro proyecto y sobre todo tratar de
acompañar los
cómo surgió surgió a partir de un
documento escrito por el papá francisco
que se llama law datos y documento en el
que llama a todos los hombres de buena
voluntad a cuidar el medio ambiente a
cuidar la casa común que es la casa de
todos
desde la dirección propusieron la idea y
se generó un grupo de trabajo para
desarrollar el programa
cuantificamos los residuos que estábamos
generando para evaluar cómo estaba el
problema
estábamos enviando o sea tirando 1300
kilos de basura por mes 1300 kilos algo
teníamos que hacer
un viernes cuando los alumnos alumnos
nos fuimos del liceo sacaron todos los
tachos viejos que había y colocaron 26
estaciones con cartelería indicativa en
lugares estratégicos
al lunes siguiente pasaron por las
clases y nos explicaron que desde ese
momento necesitaban del apoyo y del
compromiso de todos y esa es la clave
porque el programa voy a estar
perfectamente planeado pero sin el
compromiso de todos no iba a servir para
nada
pero en qué consiste el programa es un
plan participativo para disminuir
progresivamente la generación de
desechos hasta re incorporar todas las
materias primas a los ciclos productivos
oa los sistemas naturales
busca generar cambios profundos en
nuestros hábitos y formas de ver dando
un nuevo destino a nuestros desechos
el plan se dividió en etapas y empezamos
por clasificar nuestros nuestros
desechos en tres categorías reciclables
compostables y mezclados
así empezamos los 900 en el mismo
momento comprometidos con con el
proyecto respetando la ruta y el destino
de cada cosa
y conseguimos cuantificando y pesando
todo para ver cómo evolucionaba cuando
analizamos los resultados vimos que del
total que antes tiramos sólo un tercio
era realmente basura
solo en la tercera parte de lo que
tirábamos antes era realmente basura
es que si nos ponemos a pensar un minuto
y razonamos cómo nos manejamos en
nuestra casa
nosotros en nuestra casa no guardamos
todas las cosas juntas no tenemos las
cebollas con los cuadernos con la ropa
es que si tuviéramos todos juntos segura
a la hora de querer utilizar algo
estaría en mal estado manchado tal vez
roto y lo terminaríamos desechando pero
en cambio nuestra casa no hacemos eso en
nuestra casa tenemos un placar para la
ropa el estante para los artículos de
limpieza y la biblioteca para los
cuadernos
porque no son lo mismo con nuestros
desechos
y dioses hechos porque no son todo
basura se transforman en basura porque
nosotros los mezclamos seguro si alguien
quisiera utilizar alguna de las cosas
que nosotros tiramos no va a poder
porque nosotros somos quienes los
arruinamos
gran parte de nuestros desechos tienen
valor
tenemos que pensar que son nuestros
desechos pero pueden ser el sustento
para otros
por ejemplo el colegio empezó a venir a
adriana con su familia habilitado por la
intendencia ellos se llevan todas las
semanas lo reciclable y lo mezclado lo
reciclable los suv clasifican y lo
venden ese es su sustento y lo mezclado
los llevan a disposición final
por supuesto que el colegio también les
paga por brindarnos ese servicio pero de
todas formas nos salen menos que cuando
pagamos para que se llevarán el 100 por
ciento de los desechos la inversión que
hicimos en un año la recuperamos
entonces
si en nuestra casa mantenemos un orden o
lo intentamos porque no mantener un
orden en la casa común
si paramos a pensar nos damos cuenta de
nuestra falta de conciencia y esa falta
de conciencia es tan fuerte que cuando
lo pensamos resuena
el proyecto se llama resuena porque
desde un principio se pensó que debía
salir del liceo para llevarse a otros
ámbitos y ponerlo a disposición de las
instituciones de las comunidades en
general y no me refiero únicamente a la
necesidad de formar a los niños no
tenemos tiempo de que los menores nos
hagamos cargo del cuidado de nuestro
planeta
cuando el vertedero se complete vamos a
seguir siendo estudiantes
no tenemos tiempo no podemos esperar hay
que empezar ahora necesitamos que
reaccionen los adultos adultos que se
hagan cargo adultos comprometidos con el
cuidado del medio ambiente
si los adultos toman conciencia seguro
de los menores los vamos a imitar
el proyecto ya resuena en el juan
necesita que otros se apropien del
programa y que se sumen la buena noticia
es que está al alcance de todos
no necesitamos que se implementen normas
a nivel nacional podemos empezar hoy
mismo depende únicamente de cada uno de
nosotros suiza empezó a los 90 le costó
20 años llegar en uruguay podemos decir
que ni siquiera empezamos
hoy en día se habla mucho de crear
ciudades inteligentes
pero para lograrlo necesitamos tener
ciudadanos conscientes ciudadanos
comprometidos es decir ciudadanos
inteligentes para cuidar juntos la casa
común necesitamos que resuene muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]